[Applaudissements]
une qualification historique trappe une
équipe profonde en 2014 va accéder aux
seizièmes de finale de la coupe de
france après sa victoire 34 à 25 contre
argenteuil résultats qui en première
période les trappistes comptait six buts
d'avancé à la mi temps
franchement aujourd'hui ça a été fait
dès la première mi temps parce que pour
nous on s'est préparé à ce match là on a
tout donné dans les dix premières
minutes et on a fait la différence dès
le début donc on a senti que c'était pas
si l'après pour nous qu'on attend c'est
à dire que les dix premières minutes de
chaque mi temps
c'est là où se fait la différence et les
joueurs ont répondu présent donc là
c'était en tant que coach
là c'était parfait pour continuer son
épopée trèbes s'est appuyé pendant la
partie sur une grosse activité offensive
avec des gestes spectaculaires en
première période
[Applaudissements]
autre point fort de l'équipe sur ce
match la défense les trappistes ce n'ont
concédé que 25 buts face à argenteuil
une formation qui évolue pourtant une
division au dessus des trappistes de
gouverner en prenant une trentaine de
buts 32 buts par match et on a fait un
gros travail de défense pour préparer ce
match donc l'objectif a été rempli qu'on
est en défense faut être agressif forêt
il faut montrer qu'on est présent sur le
terrain donc on l'a montré en défense on
a essayé de monter de la barre
rapidement pour voilà pour apprendre
davantage
une combativité qu'il faudra conserver
au tour suivant trap est désormais le
petit poucet d'île de france et qui
pourrait affronter pendant les finales
régionales bondoufle mines et six bris
sur vingt trois équipes de prérégion la
rencontre soit programmé le week-end du
18 février mais en attendant le club
peut savourer
[Applaudissements]
à